hi
thank you for joining me uh so i'm going
to talk about shrinkage and the random
projections
and the cubic formula lower bounds for
ac 0.
this is joint work with yuval filmos and
orme ear
okay so we are talking today about
boolean functions and the model of
computation we'll consider
is the morgan formulas these are just
binary trees
with orange and gates and variables or
the negation at the bottom
here's an example this is a form of
computing x1 and x2
or x1 naught and x3
we consider two complexity measures with
respect to formulas
l of f would be the minimum number of
leaves in any formula computing a
boolean function
f notice that for a given function we
might have several
formulas computing it and dff will be
the minimal depth of a formula computing
f
depth really corresponds to parallel
time if we think of all these nodes as
working in parallel
the time that it would take values to
propagate from
leaves to root is really the depth or
the length of the longest path
from inputs to output
and this really motivates this study of
formulas or study of depth
and it turns out that understanding one
of them
and the other is essentially equivalent
due to this
relation of spira which shows that
the best depth is up to a constant log
the best
size
and we will be interested in nc1 the
class of functions that can be computed
by logarithmic depth formulas or
polynomial size formulas
so this comes from the motivation of
understanding parallel computation
can we solve anything a thousand times
faster if we have a thousand chord
and it seems intuitive that the answer
is no some tasks enjoy from parallelism
for example if we want to dig this
um long canal then the more workers we
have
the works of uh speeds up however if we
want to
dig this deep uh hole then it doesn't
seem
that no workers would have in the job
this seems inherently sequential
so can we take this intuition and make
it into a proof this is really the p
versus nc1 question
that asks whether every language in p
have logarithmic depth formulas
if so this would be amazing because it
would mean that going from
you know sequential um
from one core to too many cores we get
from polynomial time to logarithmic time
so exponential speed up
this seems too good to be true and the
intuition that some things are
inherently sequentially sort of
capturing that okay so equivalently we
can ask whether everything in pf
polynomial size formulas
indeed there's a big gap between what we
believe and what we can prove
we believe that some problems in p
require exponential formula size
or linear depth and the best that we can
prove is that some problems in p
require n cube formula size
and this problem was suggested by andre
we will see it
in a bit and the proof was given by
hasta
and today we're going to extend the
class of
problems for which we can prove this n
cube lore
all right
so i want to mention another uh big open
question
in the in the field of formula
complexity
and that is the question of what's the
formal size of composition of two
functions
so if we take f and g both of them are
boolean functions so
the first question that comes to mind is
how to compose them
and the natural idea is to take several
copies of g
applied to distinct set of input
variables
and take all these answers and fit them
into f
so this is maybe sometimes called
blocking position
and if we think of what is the formula
size of this composition
it's naturally upper bounded by the
former size of f times the formal stage
of g
you just take a formula for f and
replace every leaf with a formula for g
and karcher rods and victor zone
suggested that this is tight
okay and assuming their
conjecture is correct they provided a
construction
for which the former size would require
at least end to the logan okay in
particular
if their conjecture is correct then p is
different than nc one
resolving this big open question in
complexity
so we are still far from resolving the
krw conjecture
let me mention a few special cases um
the first are
slightly less interesting so when the
function is like the end function or the
or function
the conjecture is true and same for for
f
and more interestingly more
interestingly
when g is a party function and the party
function actually
requires quadratic formula size then the
conjecture is still true
and this is a way to get the end cube
lower bound
all right so i want to tell you more
about the ancho blog bond
the essential property that is used to
prove this lower bond
is the shrinkage of formulas under
random restrictions
let me first give you an example let's
take this
formula that we saw on the first slide
and let's now fix one of the variables
to a constant
so i'm going to fix x1 to zero this
makes these two
leaves a zero and a one and now i can
further simplify this
formula because 0 and something is 0
and 1 and x3 is x3 so i can
make this simplification and then i can
make even an additional simplification
and get that after this fixing the size
decreased from four leaves to one leaves
so there is some kind of shrinkage going
on
and this is not a coincidence
it turns out that any formula whatsoever
that you take
if you fix most of its variables to zero
one
then it shrinks by a factor of roughly n
squared
on the other hand and we have showed
that there exists an explicit
function whose formula size after the
restriction is at least
n and this means that the form size
before the restriction should have been
at least n times n squared which is nq
so in other words in order to show that
some tree is big you show that it
shrinks by a significant factor and you
show that it's not that small after
the shrinkage
to be more concrete let's see andrea's
construction he actually took a
composition of two functions
f0 is a very hard function but on a very
small domain
it's defined over log n bits and it
requires something like
formal size of n how would you get f0
notice that the description of f0
requires only
n bits of information so you can get it
as part of the input
okay so now you have f0 in your hand you
compose
f0 with the parity function over n over
log n bits
and it turns out that in this case the
kw conjectures
works and indeed the formal size of the
composition is roughly the product of
the formal size of f-zero and the
formal size of parity which gives you
the end cube
another way to to say is to say what
happened after
under the random restriction every party
function under the runner restriction
shrinks to roughly a constant number of
variables
and therefore we are left with roughly
the the complexity of f
zero and this
is a another way to see the ancube lower
bound
we are shrinking by a factor of roughly
n squared and we are of size at least
the size of f0 which is n after the
shrinkage
okay and now i want to talk about
other low bound techniques so so far we
talked about the random restriction in
shrinkage
this is denoted as a bottom-up technique
in the sense that if we look at the
formula as some
top sub-formula composed with bottom
sub-formulas
then after shrinkage all these bottom
cell formulas become
very very small maybe containing one
leaf
and and this is sort of a technique that
works from the leaves up
there's another approach
towards proving formula low balance
known as a care
sorry known as the kw games or culture
victors and games this is a
a reformulation of the question in the
language of communication complexity
the kw game with
respect to the function f is the
following
alice gets an input x such that f of x
equals one
bob gets an input y such that f of y
equals zero
their goal is to find a coordinate i
such that
x i is different than y i
indeed any protocol for the kw game with
respect to f
corresponds with a formula for the
function f
the depth of the formula corresponds to
the communication cost
and the formula three correspond to the
protocol tree
so there's really a one-to-one
corresponds between these two objects
and if we are trying to prove that
these um trees are large or that they
are deep
then this naturally uh comes down to
showing that the communication
probably requires a lot of bits of
communication and this is a top-down
approach you can think of it as if
you're starting at the top of the tree
and going down towards one of the leaves
indeed kw games uh
have proved useful in the monotone
setting where
they were used to prove a lot of lower
bounds on the
size of monotone the movement formulas
and they seem to be an also promising
approach towards the krw conjecture in
general
establishing uh intermediate milestones
moreover recently the nuremberg
gave a top-down proof in in the language
of kw games
for the end cube lower bounds so it
seems that anything that we can
prove in the bottom-up
technique can be also proved using
top-down techniques
and the question is are top-down
techniques
superior to bottom-up techniques this
was a motivating question
to our project and we had a
good candidate for demonstrating that
and the candidate is the following can
we prove an
n cube lower bond for a function in ac0
okay so we want to prove a low bond not
only for some function in p but for a
function that can be actually computed
by
constant depth unbounded fan in circuits
or ac 0 circuits
and the reason why we believe that this
is a good candidate is
for the following two bullet points
the first one is that it seemed
plausible that the techniques
of the normal can be extended to this
regime
and the second point is that we were
certain that random restriction
techniques
cannot prove the enquipler bond and the
reason for that is that
if you recall in the uh
proof overview that we showed we said
that one of the
one of the steps is to show that formula
shrinks
and the other is to show that the
function requires large
formal size after the shrinkage well if
we take a function in ac 0 and we apply
a random restriction
then this function becomes a constant
function with high probability
this is what's known as a switching
level result
so we cannot really argue that the
function is complicated after the random
restriction and therefore this seems
to to mean that random restriction
techniques
are uh inferior to top-down techniques
however we were wrong so it's true
if we apply simple random restriction
techniques
we don't know how to make it work but
if you tailor-made your random
restrictions so that they would respect
the structure of of the function
the target function f then you can
actually make it work and this is
our main result so we showed
an enqueue bloodbound for a function in
ac0 and moreover
our techniques relied on random
restriction or
more accurately random projections
so let me first start with describing
the construction what is
the function for which we show the lower
bound so this is very similar to the
function by andrea
we call it and rev has some hard
function
f zero on log n bits composed with
parity we want
to take the same idea but to implement
it using ac 0 circuits
so f0 can be computed in ac0 that's not
a problem but party cannot
so in order to do that we replace party
with function called search activities
it was considered in the past
as is a function in ac0 that
requires high quantum query complexity
and the definition of surjectivity is
the following you can think of it as a
function over beats but it's
um more convenient to think of it as a
function taking
10 m symbols in alphabet 1 up to m
okay so the subjectivity on input y 1 up
to y 10
m returns 1 if
you know you cover all the the image
meaning
every every possible uh symbols between
one two
m attains at least once is is one of the
y eyes
okay so for every j between 1 to m
the resist and i such that y i equals j
okay it's not too complicated to show
that there's a constant f circuit that
computes surjectivity
and also that f0 can be computed by
constant f and this is mainly because
it's the function only on the
log and beat and therefore their
composition is also in ac 0.
on the other hand we show that the
formal size the morgan formula size of
this function is at least n cubed
and our proof uses taylor-made
random projections so what's the random
projections
so let's first recall what's a random
restriction so if you think of all the
input variables as
x1 to xn a random restriction
randomly assigns some of these variables
zeros and one and keeps
the other ones alive a random projection
moreover projects the variable
x i to some other variable yj and this
projection can also
sort of take two variables and assign to
them the same variable y i
okay so in particular let's look at this
projection we see that
you know we have here three variables
that are mapped to y5
so now this one random variable
controls three positions in the string
and the idea is that when we design
these random projections this would not
be
a simple uh projection random
restrictions that
sort of uh make a independent decision
for each
bit individually but rather something
more coordinated
and we need to keep a balance between
two properties
the first one is that we want to
maintain the structure of the function
we want with high probability that the
function under projection would be at
least as hard as
f0 and recall that the size of f0 was
the form of size of ff0 was at least n
on the other hand we wanted with high
probability the
any formula would shrink by a factor of
n squared under this projection
okay so these are two requirements that
obviously are in tension with one
another
and we are able to to design random
projections that
that satisfy both properties
in fact the results are more general
than that
we're able to show that for any f and g
the formula size of f composed with g is
at least the formula size of
f times the kropchenko measure on g
the kropchenko lower bound is a is
another lower bound technique in formula
size lower bounds and using this
technique it was
kravchenko first showed that the formal
size of parity is at least n squared
and our results are actually stronger
than that we are able to show that
uh we can replace the krapjenko lower
bound with the unweighted adversary
lower bound squared it is known that for
any function this is at least
as big as the chain color bound
this is a lower bound technique
suggested by anderson bynes
in particular our proof shows that the
kw conjecture holds for any function g
for which the formal size of g
is um up to constant adversary
uh bound of g squared
okay and party and the surjectivity
function are both special cases of this
of this result for both of them the
formula size is quadratic and the
adversary size
is the adversary lower bound is linear
okay so i want to
give you just
a tiny bit about the proof how do we
prove this how do we come up with these
random projections that sort of maintain
structure but also shrinks
the formula so that is as follows
so we start with this with uh with a
simple example and then i'm going to
talk about how we do the random
restriction for f composed with g
so now let's just consider g
what is the krapjenko measure of g
we are looking for to maximize
the following quantity we're going over
all possible subsets
a of the ones of g and all subsets b of
the zeros of g
and we're looking at all edges on the
hypercube
between the points in a and the points
in b
we're looking at this number of edges a
b squared divided by the size of a times
the size of b
let's see an example so here
we have a boolean function g
a boolean function is corresponding to
some coloring of the boolean hypercube
where let's say that the red
vertices are the ones that for which g
attains one
and the blue are the ones for which g
attains zero
and now we are looking for a subset of
the red points and the blue points for
which we have many edges between them
and to their size okay
so in this case we would have six edges
where the size of
a and the size of p equals three and we
would have that the krapienko
bound is uh six squared over
three times three which is four okay
and now the idea is that we want to get
from from this
crop chanco lower bound we want to get
some random
restriction or random projection what
we're going to do
we're going to pick a random edge
this random edge would be one of these
edges
for which the function is sensitive on
so meaning this would be an
edge between a red point and a blue
point and each such edge
naturally defines a one-dimensional
sub-cube or in other words a projection
on which the function g is not constant
what is a projection we are just
looking at all points for which in this
case
for which the first coordinate is one
the second coordinate is zero
and the third coordinate is alive it can
be either zero or one
okay and we can see that the function is
not constant
under this projection
more generally we want to come up with
some distribution
that would respect the structure of f
composed with g recall that f composed
with g looks something like this
we have let's say fsm bits
and each one of them is the computation
of g on k bits
so the idea is as follows for each block
of k bits we're going to pick
a random sensitive edge according to g
and this would define an m-dimensional
sub-cube overall
so that's how we we pick our random
restrictions
and we show that when we take f composed
with g
under the restriction this is equivalent
to f
so this is actually not that hard to
show it's sort of by definition of
by design of the of the you know
distribution of restrictions
the higher part is our main lemma
showing that every formula shrinks by a
factor of
kroczenko of g under such a restriction
and this follows hasta proof of the
shrinkage result
in fact it follows is is proof for the
simpler
case of balanced formulas and
by doing that we are avoiding uh
complicated case analysis
i should mention that so far i've only
discussed restrictions
and the reason that we need to introduce
projections is that
the krapchenko measure is not a good
measure
for a function like the subjectivity
function
so we need to use the tools such as
projection to
to to address this point and
and for more details i would refer you
to the paper or
or maybe a catch me later for a q a
so thank you for
watching and i'll be happy to answer
your questions via email
and feel free to to send me a note
bye